[Music]
at the southern tip of the iberian
peninsula nestled in the heart of the
spanish province of cadets and
surrounded by one of the most
economically and socially depressed
areas of europe sits gibraltar it's
basically just another british overseas
territory that every now and again for
one reason or another gets a lot of
coverage in the spanish media in some
cases by new stories as alien as this
one ortega smith asked to serve 10 years
in jail in gibraltar for stealing a
concrete block
smith vox tells the pirates of gibraltar
that he is not intimidated by their
arrest warrants the rock lives off crime
spain considers this small city of just
34 000 inhabitants as the last
possession or colony of the united
kingdom on the european continent
[Music]
why well you see the sovereignty of
gibraltar was handed over by the spanish
to the british through what is known as
the treaty of utrecht in 1713. the
treaty was part of the peace settlement
after the war of spanish succession that
brought the bourbons to power despite
this disputes and territorial claims
over the city the waters surrounding it
or part of the territory it occupies
have continued to this day
[Music]
now why on earth are we a visual politic
talking about a tiny tiny seemingly
inconsequential place who really cares
about gibraltar well what if i were to
tell you that the rock has become one of
the richest and most prosperous
territories in the world listen up
[Music]
spain considers gibraltar to be the last
british colony in the european
is the unica territory existent
in the territory europe
however to be fair this is a definition
that has more holes in it than swiss
cheese for example the gibraltarian
executive is currently led by this man
chief minister fabian piccardo a man who
along with his government team enjoys a
degree of independence an almost total
self-government in terms of the
territory including being able to
develop regulations taxes and rules that
are completely different from those to
the rest of the united kingdom in
addition and despite having only 34 000
inhabitants gibraltar also has its own
constitution its last reform was carried
out in 2006. and the truth is that with
each reform the british governor has
been losing sway in favor of local
authorities so much so that we could
basically say that it is a territory
that is de facto largely independent as
if that were not enough in 1967 99.64 of
gibraltians voted in a referendum in
favour of remaining under british
sovereignty and in another referendum in
2002 no less than 98.97 percent of
gibraltians rejected shared sovereignty
with spain
[Music]
so while so many politicians in spain
insist on labeling it a colony the
reality seems very different however
despite its small population the issue
of gibraltar once again dominated the
front pages and the political debate in
spain in 2016. why well listen up
after brexit the spanish flag is now
much closer to gibraltar jose manuel
garcia magayo imar phil spanish foreign
minister between 2011 and 2016. exactly
brexit changed everything the result of
the referendum in gibraltar was
resounding no less than 95.9 percent of
gibraltians also known as the lanitos
opposed it which is not at all
surprising the fear of being isolated
and suffering losses of all kinds due to
border barriers pushed the dobrothians
to join the campaign against brexit for
example gibraltar's economy depends to a
large extent on the more than nine
thousand spanish workers who cross the
border every day to work in this british
territory so you can imagine the degree
of integration that exists despite this
the uk's departure from the eu club is
already a reality and that has made us
on visualpolitik ask ourselves a few
questions what exactly does the future
hold for gibraltar and what on earth
does the rock make money from and pay
attention because i think the answers
are going to surprise you because as i
said before gibraltar has become one of
the most prosperous places in the world
listen up
[Music]
the most prosperous rock
gibraltar has become a tremendously
prosperous area and what can i say that
that is something that really stands out
entering gibraltar means experiencing an
abysmal difference with respect to the
socio-economic situation of the spanish
territory that surrounds it it is
practically like going from one world to
the next while entering gibraltar means
being confronted with luxury towers and
developments under construction high-end
cars booming businesses and an
unemployment rate of less than one
percent the situation on the other side
of the border is completely different
there is for example the case of la line
de la concepcion
[Music]
la line de la concepcion is a spanish
city that borders gibraltar we are
talking about a city suffering from a
very complicated economic and social
situation in fact it is regularly
featured on television programs focused
on issues of crime marginality and
narcotics with around 70 youth
unemployment in some depressed
neighborhoods the city and all its
surrounding region the campo de gibralta
are the breeding ground of drugs
trafficking and insecurity it is
estimated that more than 3 000 people
are involved in the trafficking of
narcotic drugs arriving from africa
along with this smuggling of alcohol
tobacco and public subsidies are some of
the main income generating activities in
the area
evidently the differences are noticeable
all around do you want some examples
well look at this while in la linnae the
average salary barely exceeds twenty
thousand dollars or seventeen thousand
euros per year just a few thousand feet
away in gibraltar this average salary is
more than double exceeding 42 000 or 36
000 euros and take note because if we
use other statistics such as investment
or productivity differences are even
greater in fact we only need to take a
look at the economic production of this
territory to understand exactly what
we're talking about
[Music]
to give you an idea despite its 34 000
inhabitants and its ridiculous size it
is expected that the gdp will soon
exceed 3.5 billion dollars a figure that
has already been reached before the
pandemic we're talking about a gdp per
capita of about 100 thousand dollars in
other words while gibraltar is becoming
one of the most prosperous territories
in europe and even in the whole world
with an average real growth rate of
almost 7 per year during the 10 years
prior to the coronavirus the spanish
area surrounding it is by contrast one
of the most depressed areas on the
european union now the question that we
are all wondering is where the hell do
the yanitos the gibraltians get their
money from how can such a tiny place be
so prosperous well obviously with only
6.8 kilometers squared of surface area
most of which is also occupied by the
big rock by the massive rock the options
are limited there's zero percent primary
sector and practically zero percent
industry this territory is almost
entirely dedicated to services we can
identify four outstanding activities the
port finance tourism and perhaps above
all online gaming let's go through them
all one by one
gibraltar is one of the main ports in
the mediterranean sea for the reloading
of fuel known as bunkering which
constitutes between 85 and 90 of the
port's total activity its leadership in
this area is largely due to the fact
that the refuelling of merchant ships in
gibraltar is tax-free the second major
activity in gibraltar is finance and
insurance an industry that the local
government has been promoting for years
so much so that despite being such a
small place around 20 international
banks have headquarters or branches
there where they are almost exclusively
dedicated to the management of offshore
financial assets gibraltar is not a tax
haven but it has brought agile
regulation and moderate taxation to the
table for example it does not tax
capital gains and was one of the first
jurisdictions on the planet to create a
regulatory framework adapted to fintech
another example it's relatively low
corporate income tax currently at 12.5
has helped many companies to establish
their headquarters here to the extent
that there are some 15
500 companies registered in this small
territory of 34 000 inhabitants
then there's tourism another major
attraction of this place
every year between 11 and 12 million
tourists and visitors go to the rock
which means it has one of the highest
tourist-to-resident ratios in the world
and no it's not a coincidence in
addition to its peculiarities and the
absence of indirect taxes so far tourism
development and the attraction of large
fortunes is something that the
authorities and local businessmen have
taken very very seriously there is for
example the development of marinas such
as the ocean village which you see on
screen in addition there is the current
investment of 300 million dollars to
develop victoria keys a complex of 1.4
million square feet that's 130 000
metres square on land reclaimed from the
sea that will contain among other things
1 500 luxury apartments commercial
spaces and a hotel but wait a minute
because if there is one industry in
which gibraltar stands out worldwide
it's none other than online gambling
online casinos
[Music]
you see since the 2005 gambling law was
passed by the government of the rock the
gambling industry has exploded to such
an extent that some of the biggest
online gambling companies in the world
are based right here in gibraltar i'm
talking about companies like william
hill 888 betfred and many others
gibraltar is a huge global online
gambling hub but why why have these
companies chosen gibraltar well among
other things because this place has one
of the most advanced regulations in the
world a regulatory commission that tries
to move with the times they put
everything on the line to be competitive
and taxes are low on gambling
gibraltar has a business friendly
approach that makes it easy for good
companies to set up and operate there
are many local advisors ready to support
startups and the relevant government
representatives and their teams are
approachable and hands-on in their
support julian jarvis is the ceo of
pragmatic play in total financial
industry and online gambling account for
around 40 of all local gdp
as we've seen on other occasions one of
the great advantages of these micro
jurisdictions is that both the
authorities and the population itself
have many incentives to exploit the
competitive advantages so much so that
they usually behave almost like
companies with a mission to adapt to the
times as quickly as possible and
maximize the creation of economic
activity and that is precisely the case
of the rock of gibraltar whose
government may have many flaws but not
only does it constantly adopt advanced
and competitive regulations for the
professional services industry it also
works hard to attract companies and
investments to move forward with high
valley projects and to improve the local
ecosystem for example despite having
only 34 000 inhabitants in 2015
gibraltar began operating its own value
market the gibraltar stock exchange the
results are plain to see however wait a
minute because now brexit has created a
turning point and the question we can
now ask is to what extent can gibraltar
lose or gain from all this political
revolution listen up after the uk after
breakfast
not breakfast
that'd be brexit okay yes a chaotic
breakfast that will damage our economy
okay let us stay with the theme of
breakfast we will make breakfast
breakfast a success
this worldwide export drive saying
breakfast break oh my lord the rock
after brexit
despite what many believe the truth is
that so far in practice brexit in
gibraltar has not been noticed too much
apart from the replacement of the
european flag by the commonwealth flag
this was because the terms of the united
kingdom's exit from the european union
did not apply to gibraltar the status of
which was agreed to be negotiated
separately and precisely to avoid a hard
brexit that would have meant many
obstacles for both the rock and for the
spanish workers and suppliers who live
in this british enclave after the agreed
transition period the governments of the
three parties involved spain the united
kingdom and gibraltar promoted the
so-called new year's eve agreement it's
a political agreement that as you can
guess from the name came about in
extremis on 31st december 2020
[Music]
the new year's eve agreement was the
first step to completely changing the
situation of the rock with its
surroundings the agreement reached which
now has to be finalized with the
european union includes the free
movement of people and goods which means
incorporating gibraltar for the first
time to the schengen area this will
entail the disappearance of the fence
popularly known as la virga the customs
crossing and the controls that existed
at the border between spain and the
british territory but that also means
that british citizens will have to pass
a passport control to enter gibraltar
something that other european citizens
will not have to do in fact migration
control of the gibraltar port and
airport will be under the control of the
european union specifically frontex and
the european border and coast guard
agency and not only that in theory the
customs and foreign trade policy of the
european union will also apply in
gibraltar which will also affect any
products coming from the united kingdom
the gibraltarian authorities will also
have to implement regulatory changes to
bring them into line with eu rules on
for example vat or excise duties
in other words although it will remain
under british sovereignty the rock will
be more closely linked than ever to eu
policy obviously friction is guaranteed
[Music]
without walking too far on 20th of july
2021 the european commission presented
the draft that will lay the foundations
for the negotiation of the future
relationship between the two parties
once the four-year transitional period
has passed among other things this draft
envisages that border control will no
longer be in the hands of frontex but
directly under the control of the
spanish authorities and their security
forces a proposal that quickly caused
the fury to erupt
uk clashes with eu over gibraltar's
post-brexit status the foreign secretary
has accused the eu of seeking to
undermine the uk's sovereignty over
gibraltar and take note because in
gibraltar the debate is inevitable while
the government defends the agreement
with the european union much of the
opposition is not so clear they are
afraid that the eu rules and
requirements may end up eroding local
prosperity at visualpolitik we'll be
keeping an eye out but for now it's your
turn what do you think about gibraltar
and will this tiny place become a global
reference from what you've heard what do
you like and what don't you like as
always leave us your answers in the
comments below and if you found this
video interesting then don't forget to
hit that like button too thank you very
much for being here and i'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
[Applause]